[Music]
foreign
Middleton back on the world stage yet
again
yeah just days after fulfilling her
royal duties at the king's coronation
the Princess of Wales shocked fans
watching the Eurovision finale showing
off her piano skills inside Windsor
Castle
[Music]
what's that tune well it's Ukraine's
winning song from last year
[Music]
of course Eurovision is a global talent
show phenomenon I Wanna Stop the clocks
and hold you close it was even the
subject of a 2020 comedy flick starring
Will Ferrell and Rachel McAdams I think
the thing that that Eurovision has that
we just don't have in our kind of
singing contest here is just this
dramatic Flair
so how many in England watched Kate's
performance well the BBC reports nearly
10 million people tuned in for the
finale all this I promise to do
meanwhile the previous weekend over 14
million Brits watched Charles Ascend the
throne God Saves The King
okay
and speaking of the newly crowned
Monarch now we're trying to figure out
what can we do to bring some something
different to the show his majesty
alongside Queen Camilla in another Royal
Cameo shocked everyone on American Idol
okay
surprise I have a surprise
because I just wanted to check
um how much how long you'll be using
this room for
we have to give the room up I was
driving in and my phone rings as
executive producer and she says well
we've got some news I just wanted to
check meanwhile it was judges Lionel
Richie and Katy Perry who were the
special guests at the coronation concert
I would say a few words about my father
but don't worry unlike Lionel I won't go
on all night long
[Music]
what a party what a party it was
unbelievable it's an honor I've known
him a long time but to be asked is this
is the whole thing I got to bring my mom
she is so happy to be here
[Music]
[Applause]
are we Kitty about it well Katie was
giddy but as for Kate she sticks on the
side of calm and collected
okay it's not quite a queen yet but her
piano playing is royalty at its finest
[Music]